99.
[Silence]
Shame.
Mama.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the book of purification of
so we mentioned yesterday as the author
took us into the second half of
purification for salah.
And this purification
is referred to specifically
as
we said that hadith is a state of
spiritual impurity
that prevents a person from three
things, right? Three things.
Number one,
[Arabic recitation]
, handling the mus and number three is
around the three things that a person
who does not have wudoo may not do
without
having that purification without an
excuse. Anything outside of that isab
is but as we'll hear there's plenty of
instances when it is when it is
preferred that a person make woo before
going to sleep before reengaging in
intimacy with one's wife etc. These are
all things that before eating if a
person is in a state of janaba we will
list those things as they come up. But
the three
things that are haram for a person to
do in a state of hadith is salah
and handling the mus. Okay. So we
mentioned that this type of
it is two types.
purification or
with wa using using water and the other
with using
you know using water or using
so the author begins with the most
common and that is
so now he's going to list for us the
he's going to mention for us the most
popularly cited and most comprehensive
description of the prophet's wudoo
sallam
that is found in the sunnah. This
narration is known as the narration of
also known as the narration of because
it is on his authority. Arman shows us
how he used to make wudoo. Now remember
this is the most comprehensive
and this is the one cited as the essence
of this. This doesn't mean
is the only person who narrated the
prophet's wudoo.
Dozens of companions narrated his wudoo.
But all in one
place, all the details, the most
comprehensive all together in one place
is the narration of and this is why
students begin with memorizing this
narration and then they memorize the
add-ons. This narration is in Bkari
Muslim.
So the narration is known as the
narration of Arthan. It's also known as
the narration of Omran was man's freed
slave. This is one of the men that he
had owned as a slave. He freed him and
he remained loyal to him and used to
serve him especially during his time in
his
okay. He is one of the
In doing
[Silence]
for
meth.
[Silence]
across the board.
formul.
[Silence]
was
for
[Silence]
I've seen some people.
Yeah, we we'll get to that. Yes, we will
get to that inshallah.
forch.
[Silence]
I can be sure.
[Arabic recitation]
called for some water to make woo and
then he demonstrated the prophet's wudi
wasallam. Now
what we're going to do is at first he's
going to mention the most comprehensive
narration
right this is the ideal
the idyllic wuboo is as follows then
he's going to take us into the
technicalities
what are the technicalities the
conditions the wajat the you know
what is sunnah what is mustab what is
waj what is right
that is the technical side
but when it comes to how we would make
wudoo the idyllic wudoo
this is the picture of idilic wudoo
he says he began with washing his hands
meaning to the wrist three times
and then he rinsed his mouth and blew
his nose. Notice how here he says
rinsed his mouth and blew his nose.
Meaning together these things came
together which means that he put the
water in his mouth and then put the rest
into his nose and then would blow it out
and spit the water out.
and how would he do this? He would
take the water with his hand, put half
into his mouth, the rest he would suck
into his nose deeply, but not deep
enough to where it is going into his
sinuses deeply, right? And then he would
move the water around because
[Silence]
So he'd put the water in his mouth and
then move the water around.
And this is with his right and then with
his left he would blow it out and then
spit the water out. Right? So it is it
is looking this. Put the half in
half into the nose. move it around, spit
it out, and then blow the water out of
his nose three times.
There's different ways that he did this.
There's three different ways that he did
this. Never did he separate the mouth
and the nose in any narration ever.
Meaning doing the mouth three times and
then the nose three times. Is it valid?
Yes, it's valid. Is it the sunnah? No,
it's not the sunnah, which we'll get to
inshallah.
He says,
"And then he washed his face three
times." And we'll talk about the
parameters of the face in in its place
inshallah. And then he washed his right
hand and arm
to include the elbow.
And then he did the same for his left.
So when he goes to wash,
he would wash the hand
all the way to the elbow
and include the elbow. Okay? So he's
washing to here.
And how would he do that? He didn't have
running water obviously.
So he would dip his hand in,
pour the water down his arm this,
and then move it around with his other
hand to include his left. And then he
would do the right from the top of the
hand. Right? The water would go down to
include his left.
Ini
he would then take extra water and pour
it on his elbow to make sure that he got
it the right. Then he would pour it on
his elbow and the left.
He says,
"And then he wiped over his head."
Which part of his head? All of his head.
He would wipe all over his head. How
many times? One time.
And that's what he mentioned here. And
in this wording, he only wiped his head.
It doesn't go into detail. Did he wipe
it back and then forth? Did he wipe it
once back? Did he? That is something
that is detailed elsewhere sun
abid.
And then he washed his right foot to
include the two
ankles and then his left foot to include
the two ankles. And then he said, "I saw
the messenger of Allah sall.ai wasam
perform his wudoo in the way that you
all have just seen me perform wudoo."
And he said after per upon completing
this wudoo, whoever
makes wudoo in the fashion that I have
just made woo and then stands and makes
two raqa without losing his focus once.
Meaning the person does not hear his
inner monologue one time.
You you know that voice in your head,
huh? That's me. That's you
doesn't hear that voice the whole time.
The only thing is he is reciting
and he himself
has dissolved. The only thing there is
his recitation,
his
completely loses himself in the prayer,
right?
Does not think outside of the prayer
once, not even fleeingly.
What is passed of his sins will be
forgiven. That's a very lofty
reward, right? That's a very
major reward for something that seems to
be very simple. He's forgiven of his
sins, his past sins for doing this, for
making and and making salah. Yes. But
the catch
is that
he does not even fleetingly, not even
once, not even one moment,
lose his focus or
hear his inner monologue. Not once.
How much practice would it take for a
person to be able to do that?
How many years of practice?
And that is the point of the narration.
The amount of time it would take for a
person to train him his mind to be
strong enough to make it through
entirely without losing his focus. Not
even briefly, not even fleetingly, not
even for a moment. It would take years
of practice perhaps. And there are many,
many, many Muslim men that have never
experienced this, not once. And the
reason for that is that this takes an
incredible amount of practice and
self-control, concentration,
right? Because salah
is a muscle.
You have to work it out. So when you
first start to make salah, your mind
wanders because it's undisiplined.
Your mind is undisiplined.
And so you start to make salah and then
suddenly your mind is elsewhere and then
you realize that your mind is elsewhere.
So you grab your mind by the
by the collar and you bring it back,
right? And then again and then again and
then again. And
[Silence]
Did you fix it yesterday?